the thing is most cars today are pretty
good they're all well made they're all
safe and they're all reliable the thing
that's going to make a big difference
for consumers when they buy their next
car isn't so much about what's under the
hood or behind the wheels but about how
they interact with the car how they live
with it on a day-to-day basis and that
means that the future of the car is
pretty much all about the future of the
dashboard this is the first look at
outies 2015 q7 interiors for starters
they have the traditional mm I
controller but what they've also done is
they've added a larger touch pad so that
you can actually draw the letters that
you wish to use for entering data into
the main computer taxi drivers aren't
left out of the action either Audi has
created its own android tablet which
docks right here onto the back of the
seat and allows you to access much of
the same information and functions as
you would at the front of the car in
fact you can even select a destination
using the map software here and send it
right to the main navigation system of
the car up front this is a concept
interior that BMW is showing here at CES
but what it shows is that BMW is
actually finally bridging the gap
between rotary controllers and touch
screens BMW is adding an additional way
to interact with your car gestures and
overhead camera is detecting this area
right here for example I can change the
volume on the audio system simply by
swirling my finger up or down and the
car will respond automatically
this car is not going to be rolling into
your showrooms next year or even in five
years this is a 20-year concept from
mercedes-benz it's their F 0 15 concept
sedan and of course the first obvious
thing you're going to notice about it is
that I am NOT facing the dashboard
that's because of course this car can
drive itself and if a car can drive
itself it really has a major effect on
how interiors are going to be designed
you can turn around and start talking to
your friends and other passengers
meanwhile you can still access
information and data on these screens on
the side of the vehicle by calling up
these menus you're able to use a touch
screen that allows you to change the
music the climate the destination that
you're going to if you choose to drive
the car everything on the dashboard is
gesture control and uses sophisticated I
tracking technology to make sure that
you're not just waving at a friend or
making an unrelated gesture and actually
manipulating one of the controls on the
vehicle we can do more things than ever
while we're behind the wheel and all
this technology is about making sure we
do that in the safest way possible that
is of course until we're no longer
driving the cars ourselves